[LOGO MUSIC]
KONSTANTINOS KATSIAPIS:
Hello everyone.
My name is Gus Katsiapis.
And together with my colleagues
Kevin Haas and Tulsee Doshi,
we will talk to you today
about TensorFlow Extended,
and the topic covers two areas.
Let's go into that
I think most of you here that
have used ML in the real world
realize that machine learning
is a lot more than just a model.
It's a lot more than
just training a model.
And especially, when machine
learning powers your business
or powers a product that
actually affects your users,
you absolutely need
the reliability.
So, today, we'll talk
about how, in the face
of massive data
and the real world,
how do you build
applications that
use machine learning that
are robust to the world
that they operate in?
And today's talk will
actually have two parts.
The first part will be about
TensorFlow Extended, otherwise
known as TFX.
This is an end-to-end
machine learning platform.
And the second part
of the talk will
talk about model understanding
and how you can actually
get insights into your
business by understanding
how your model performs
in real-world situations.
OK.
So let's get started with
the first part, TensorFlow
Extended, otherwise
known as TFX.
We built TFX at Google.
We started building it
approximately two and a half
years ago.
And a lot of the knowledge that
went into building TFX actually
came from experience we
had building other machine
learning platforms within
Google that preceded it,
that preceded TensorFlow even.
So TFX has had a profound
impact to Google,
and it's used throughout
several Alphabet companies
and also in several products
within Google itself.
And several of those products
that you can see here--
like Gmail or Add, et
cetera, or YouTube--
have pretty large scale.
So they affect billions
of users, et cetera.
So this is one
more reason for us
to pay extra attention
to building systems that
use ML reliably.
Now, when we started
building TFX,
we had published
a paper about it,
and we promised we
would eventually
make it available to
the rest of the world.
So over the last
few years, we've
been open sourcing aspects of
it, and several of our partners
externally have actually
been pretty successful
deploying this technology,
several of the libraries we
have offered over time.
So just to call out an
interesting case study
that Twitter made, they actually
made a fascinating blog post
where they spoke about how they
ranked tweets with TensorFlow
and how they used
TensorFlow Hub in order
to do transfer learning
and shared word embeddings
and share them within
their organization.
And they also showcased how they
use TensorFlow Model Analysis
in order to have a better
understanding of their model--
how their model performs
not just globally
over the population, but several
slices of their population
that were important
to the business.
So we'll be talking
about more of this
later, especially with the
model understanding talk.
Now I think most of you here
are either software developers
or software engineers
or are very much
familiar with software
processes and technologies.
So I think most of
you probably recognize
several of the themes
presented in this slide,
like scalability, extensibility,
modularity, et cetera.
But, my conjecture is
that most people think
about those concepts in terms of
code and how to build software.
Now, with the advent
of machine learning,
we are building
applications that
are powered by machine
learning, which
means that those applications
are powered by data--
fundamentally are
powered by data.
So if you just think about code
and you don't think about data,
you're only thinking
about half of the picture,
50% of the picture.
So you can optimize
one amazingly.
But if you don't think
about the other half,
you cannot be better
than the half--
than the half itself.
So I would actually
encourage everyone just
to take each of those
concepts and see,
how does this concept apply to
data as opposed to just code?
And if you can apply these
concepts to both data and code,
you can build a
holistic application
that is actually robust
and powers your products.
So we will actually
go into each of those
individually and see how they
apply to machine learning.
OK.
Let's start with scalability.
Most of you know that, when
you start your business,
it might be small.
But the reality is that,
as your business grows,
so might your data.
So, ideally, you
want a solution that
is able to over time scale
together with your business.
Ideally, you would be able
to write a single library
or software--
piece of software--
and that's also could
operate on a laptop
because you want to
experiment quickly,
but it could also operate
on a beefy machine
with tons of processors
or a ton of accelerators.
And you could also scale it
over hundreds or thousands
of machines if you need to.
So this flexibility in terms
of scale is quite important.
And ideally, each time you hop
from kilobytes to megabytes
to gigabytes to
terabytes, ideally
you wouldn't have to use
different tools because you
have a huge learning curve each
time you change your technology
under the covers.
So the ideal here is to have a
machine learning platform that
is able to work on your
laptop but can also scale it
on any cloud you would like.
OK.
Now, let's talk
about accessibility.
So everyone here
understands that you
can have libraries and
components that make up
your system, and
you can have things
that work out of the box.
But, you always want to
customize it a little bit
to meet your goals.
You always want to put custom
business logic in some part
of your application.
And this is similar
for machine learning.
So if you think about
the concrete example,
when you fit data into
machine learning model,
you need to do multiple
transformations
to put the data in a format
that the model expects.
So as a developer of
an ML application,
you want to have the
transformation flexibility
that an ML platform
can provide to you--
whether that's bucketizing,
creating vocabularies,
et cetera.
And that's just one example,
but this applies pervasively
throughout the ML process.
OK.
Let's talk a little
bit about modularity.
All of you probably
understand the importance
of having nice APIs and
reusable libraries that
allow you to build bigger
and bigger systems.
But, going back to
our original question,
how does this apply to artifacts
produced by machine learning
pipelines?
How does this apply to data?
So ideally, I would be able to
reuse the reusable components
of a model that was trained
to recognize images and take
that part--
the reusable part of it--
and put it in my model that
predicts kinds of chairs.
So ideally, we would be able to
reuse parts of models as easy
as it would be to
reuse libraries.
So check out TensorFlow
Hub, which actually allows
you to reuse the reusable parts
of machine learning models
and plug them into your
own infrastructure.
And going a step further, how
does this apply to artifacts?
So machine learning
platforms usually
produce lots of data
artifacts, whether that's
statistics about your
data or something else.
And many times, those operate
in a continuous fashion.
So data continuously
arrives into the system,
and you have to
continuously produce
models that mimic
reality quickly,
that understand reality faster.
And, if you have to redo
computation from scratch,
then it means that you can
sometimes not follow real time.
So somehow you need to be
able to take artifacts that
are produced over time
and merge them easily,
quickly together so
that you can follow
real time as new data arrives.
OK.
Moving on to the
stability, most of us
are familiar with unit tests,
integration tests, regression
tests, performance tests.
All of those are about code.
What does it mean to
write a test about data?
ML and data are very
much intertwined.
What is the equivalent of a unit
test or an integration test?
If we take a step back,
when we write tests,
we encode expectations
of what happens in code.
So when we deal with
applications that have both
code and data, we need to write
expectations both in terms
of the code-- how
the code behaves--
and in terms of what is
the shape of the data
that goes into this black
box, this black process.
So I would say that the
equivalent of a unit test
or an integration test for
data is writing expectations
about types of the data
that goes into your system,
the distributions you expect,
the values that are allowed,
the values that are
not allowed, et cetera.
And we'll be discussing
about those later.
If we take this a step
further, code oftentimes
gives us very strong contracts.
When you have a
sorting algorithm,
you can expect that
it will do exactly
what the contract promises.
When you have a
machine learning model,
basically you can think of it
as a function that was generated
automatically through data.
So you don't have as strong
contracts as we had before.
So in order to set expectations
about how those black box
functions that were
created by data behave,
we need to set expectations
about what the data that
went into them was.
And this relates a lot
to the previous stability
point we mentioned.
OK.
Moving on a little bit more
from a systems view perspective,
ideally when you
use an application,
you won't have to code
everything yourself.
You would be able to reuse
several components out
of the box that accept
well-defined configuration,
and the configuration
is ideally also
flexible enough for you to
parameterize it a little bit
and customize it to your needs.
So reuse as many black boxes
as possible, but touch them up
when you need to.
This is very similar
to machine learning.
Ideally, I wouldn't have
to rebuild everything
from scratch.
I would be able to reuse
components, libraries, modules,
pipelines.
And I would be
able to share them
with multiple folks within
my business or publicly.
OK.
Now, once you have a
system and it's actually
responsible for the
performance of your product
or your business, you need
to know what's going on.
So you need to be able to
continuously monitor it and get
alerted when things are not
moving as one would expect.
And, once again, here
I would say that data
is a first-class citizen.
So unexpected changes to the
data coming into your system--
whether that's your training
system or your serving system--
need to be monitored
because, otherwise,
you cannot know what the
behavior of the system will be
especially in the absence
of those strong contracts we
discussed earlier.
So both data need to be
first-class citizens,
and both models need to
be first-class citizens.
And we need to be
able to monitor
the performance of the
models as well over time.
Now, if we apply those concepts,
we can build better software.
And if we apply the
concepts we just
discussed to
machine learning, we
can build better software
that employs machine learning.
So this should, in
principle, allow
us to build software
that is safer.
And safe is a very
generic word, but let
me try to define it
a little bit here.
I would call it
maybe a robustness
to environment changes.
So, as the data that
undergirds your system changes,
you should be able
to have a system that
is robust to it, that
performs properly
in light of those changes, or
at least you get notified when
those changes happen so that
you change the system to become
more robust in the future.
And how do we do this?
It's actually hard.
I think the reality
is that all of us
build on collective
knowledge and experience.
When we reuse
libraries, we build
on the shoulders of giants
that built those libraries.
And machine learning
is not any different.
I think the world
outside is complex.
And if you build any system
that tries to mimic it,
it has to mirror some
of the complexities.
Or, if you build a system
that tries to predict it,
it has to be able to mirror
some of those complexities.
So what comes to the rescue
here is, I would say,
automation and best practices.
So if we apply some best
practices for machine learning
that have been proven to
be useful in various other
circumstances, they're probably
useful for your business
as well.
And many of those
are difficult. We
oftentimes spend days or
months debugging situations.
And then, once we are able to
do that, we can encode the best
practices we learn
into the ML software
so that you don't need
to reinvent the wheel,
basically, in this area.
And the key here
is that learning
from the pitfalls of others
is very important to building
your own system.
OK.
So how do we achieve
those in machine learning?
Let's look into a
typical user journey
of using ML in a product
and what this looks like.
In the beginning, you
have data ingestion.
As we discussed,
data and code are
tightly intertwined
in machine learning.
And sometimes, in order to
change your machine algorithm,
you have to change your
data and vice versa.
So these need to be
tightly intertwined,
and you need something that
brings the data into the system
and applies the best practices
we discussed earlier.
So it shuffles the training data
so that downstream processes
can operate efficiently
and learn faster.
Or, it splits your
data into the training
and evolved set in
a way that make sure
is that there is no leakage of
information during this split.
For example, if you have
a financial application,
you want to make sure
that the future does not
look into the past where
you're training, just
as a current example.
OK.
Once we are able to
generate some data,
we need to make sure that
data is of good quality.
And why is that?
The answer is very simple.
As we discussed,
garbage in, garbage out.
This applies especially
well to machine
learning because ML is
this kind of black box
that is very complicated.
So if you put things in that
you don't quite understand,
there is no way for you
to be able to understand
the output of the model.
So data understanding
is actually
required for model
understanding.
We'll be talking about
this later as well.
Another thing here is
that, if you catch errors
as early as possible, that
is critical for your machine
learning application.
You reduce your wasted
time because now you've
identified the
error early on where
it's easier to actually spot.
And you actually decrease
the amount of computation
you perform.
I don't need to train
a very expensive model
if the data that's going
into it is garbage.
So this is key.
And I think the TL;DR here
is that you should treat data
as you treat code.
They're a first-class citizen
in your ML application.
OK.
Once you have your
data, sometimes you
need to massage it
in order to fit it
into your machine
learning algorithm.
So oftentimes, you might
need to build vocabularies
or you need to normalize
your constants in order
to fit into your neural network
or your linear algorithm.
And, in order to
do that, you often
need full passes over the data.
So the key thing is
that, when you train,
you do these full
passes over the data.
But when you serve, when
you evaluate your model,
you actually have one
prediction at a time.
So how can we create the
hermetic representation
of a transformation that
requires the full possibility
of data and be able to apply
that hermetic presentation
at serving time so that
my training and serving
way of doing things
is not different?
If those are different, my
model would predict bogus.
So we need to have processes
that ensure those things are
hermetic and equivalent.
And ideally, you would have a
system that does that for you.
OK.
Now that we have
data, now that we
have data that is
of good quality
because we've
validated it, and now
that we have
transformations that
allows us to fill the
data into the model,
let's train the model.
That's where the magic
happens, or so we think,
when in reality everything else
before it is actually needed.
But the chain doesn't stop here.
Once you produce a
model, you actually
need to validate the
quality of the model.
You need to make sure
it passes a threshold
that you think are
sufficient for your business
to operate in.
And ideally, you would do
this not just globally--
how does this model perform on
the total population of data--
but also how it performs on each
individual slice of the user
base you care about--
whether that's
different countries
or different populations
or different geographies
or whatever.
So, ideally, you
would have a view
not just how the model
does holistically,
but in each slice where
you're interested in.
Once you've performed
this validation,
you now have something that
we think is of good quality,
but we want to have a separation
between our training system--
which oftentimes
operates at large scale
and at high throughput--
from our serving system that
actually operates
with low latency.
When you try to
evaluate the model,
sometimes you want a
prediction immediately--
within seconds or
milliseconds even.
So you need a separation
between your training
part of the system and your
serving part of the system,
and you need clear
boundaries between those two.
So you need something
that takes a model,
decides whether
it's good or not,
and then pushes it
into production.
Once your model
is in production,
you're now able to make
predictions and improve
your business.
So as you can see,
machine learning
is not about the
middle part there.
This is not about
training your model.
Machine learning is about
the end-to-end thing
of using it in order to
improve an application
or improve a product.
So TFX has, over the
course of several years,
open sourced several
libraries and components
that make use of
those libraries.
And the libraries are
very, very modular,
going back to the previous
things we discussed.
And they can be stitched
together into your existing
infrastructure.
But, we also offer components
that understand the context--
and Kevin will be talking
about this later--
we understand the
context they are in,
and they can connect
to each other
and operate in unison as opposed
to operating as single things.
And we also offer
some horizontal layers
that allow you to do those
connections, both in terms
of configuration-- like
you have a single way
to configure your pipeline--
and in terms of data
storage and metadata storage.
So those components
understand both the state
of the world, what exists
there, and how they can
be connected with each other.
And we also offer
an entrance system.
So we give you
the libraries that
allow you to build your
system if you want, build
your car if you will, but
we also offer a car itself.
So we offer an
entrance system that
gives you well-defined
configuration,
simple configuration
for you to use.
It has several
components that work out
of the box to help you with the
user journey we just discussed,
which as we saw has
multiple phases.
So we have components that
work for each of those phases.
And we also have
a metadata store
in the bottom that allows
you to track basically
everything that's happening in
this machine learning platform.
And, with this, I
would like to invite
Kevin Haas to talk
a little bit more
about the effects
and the details.
KEVIN HAAS: Thanks, Gus.
So my name is
Kevin Haas, and I'm
going to talk about
the internals of TFX.
First a little bit of
audience participation.
How many out there know Python?
Raise your hands.
All right.
Quite a few.
How many know TensorFlow?
Raise your hands.
Oh, quite a few.
That's really good.
And how many of you
want to see code?
Raise your hands.
A lot less than the
people who know Python.
OK.
So I'm going to get to
code in about five minutes.
First, I want to talk a
little bit about what TFX is.
First off, let's talk
about the component.
The component is the
basic building block
of all of our pipelines.
When you think about a pipeline,
it's an assembly of components.
So, using this, we
have ModelValidator.
ModelValidator is one
of our components,
and it is responsible
for taking two models--
the model that we just trained
as part of this pipeline
execution and the model
that runs in production.
We then measure the accuracy
of both of these models.
And if the
newly-trained model is
better than the
model in production,
we then tell a
downstream component
to push that model
to production.
So what we have here is
two inputs-- two models--
and an output-- a decision
whether or not to push.
The challenge here
is the model that's
in production has
not been trained
by this execution
of the pipeline.
It may not have been trained
by this pipeline at all.
So we don't have a
reference to this.
Now, an easy answer
would be, oh, just hard
code it somewhere
in your config,
but we want to
avoid that as well.
So we get around this by using
another project like Google
put together called ML Metadata.
With ML Metadata,
we're able to get
the context of all
prior executions
and all prior artifacts.
This really helps us a
lot in being able to say,
what is the current
production model
because, we can query
the ML Metadata store
and ask for the
URI, the artifact,
of the production model.
Once we have that, then
now we have both inputs
that are able to go to the
validator to do our testing.
Interestingly enough, it's
not just the production model
that we get from ML Metadata,
but we get all of our inputs
from ML Metadata.
If you look here, the trainer
when it emits a new model
writes it to ML Metadata.
It does not pass it directly
to the next component
of ModelValidator.
When ModelValidator starts
up, it gets both of the models
from ML Metadata, and then
it writes back the validation
outcome back to the
ML Metadata store.
What this does is
it does two things.
One, it allows us to compose
our pipelines a lot more loosely
and so have tightly
coupled pipelines.
And two, it separates
the orchestration layer
from how we manage state
and the rest of our metadata
management.
So a little bit more about
how a component is configured.
So we have three main
phases of our component.
It's a very specific
design pattern
that we've used for
all of TFX, and we
find it works really well with
machine learning pipelines.
First, we have the driver.
The driver is responsible
for additional scheduling
and orchestration that
we may use to determine
how the executor behaves.
For example, if
we're asked to train
a model using the very
same examples as before,
the very same inputs
as before, the very
same runtime
parameters as before,
and the same version
of the estimator,
we can kind of guess
that we're going
to end up with the same
model that we started with.
As a result, we may choose
to skip the execution
and return back a
cached artifact.
This saves us both
time and compute.
Next, we have the executor.
What the executor
is responsible for
is the business logic
of the component.
In the case of the
ModelValidator,
this is where we test both
models and make a decision.
In the case of the
trainer, this is
where we train the
model using TensorFlow.
Going all the way back to the
beginning of the pipeline,
in the case of
example.jm, this is
where we extract the data
out of either a data store
or out of BigQuery or
out of the file system
in order to generate the
examples that the rest
of the pipeline trains with.
Finally we have the
publishing phase.
The publishing phase is
responsible for writing back
whatever happened
in this component
back to the metadata store.
So if the driver decided to
skip work, we write that back.
If an executor created
one or more new artifacts,
we also write that
back to ML Metadata.
So artifacts and
metadata management
are a crucial element of
managing our ML pipelines.
If you look at this, this is
a very simple task dependency
graph.
We have transform.
When it's done,
it calls trainer.
It's a very simple
finish-to-start dependency
graph.
So while we can model
our pipelines this way,
we don't because task
dependencies alone
are not the right way
to model our goals.
Instead, we actually look
at this as a data dependency
graph.
We're aware of all
the artifacts that
are going into these
various components,
and the components will be
creating new artifacts as well.
In some cases, we can
actually use components
that were not created by
the current pipeline or even
this pipeline configuration.
So what we need is
some sort of system
that's able to both schedule and
execute components but also be
task-aware and maintain
a history of all
the previous executions.
So, what's the metadata store?
First off, the metadata
store will keep information--
I guess I click here--
the metadata store
will keep information
about the trained models--
so, for example, the artifacts,
the type of the artifacts
that have been trained
by previous components.
Second, we keep a list
of all the components
and all the versions,
all the inputs and all
the runtime parameters that were
provided to these components.
So this gives us history
of what's happened.
Now that we have
this, we actually
have this bi-directional graph
between all of our artifacts
and all of our components.
What this does is it gives us
a lot of extra capabilities
where we can do advanced
analytics and metrics off
of our system.
An example of this is
something called lineage.
Lineage is where you want to
know where all your data has
passed through the system
or all of the components.
So, for example, what
were all the models that
were created by a
particular data set
is something that we could
use with ML Metadata?
On the flip side, what
were all the components
or all the artifacts
that were created
by a very particular
version of a component?
We can answer that question
as well using ML Metadata.
This is very important
for debugging,
and it's also very
important for our enquiries
when somebody says, how
has this data been consumed
by any of your pipelines?
Another example where
prior state helps us
is warm starting.
Warm starting is a
case in TensorFlow
where you incrementally
train a model using
the checkpoints in the
weights of a previous version
of the model.
So here, because we know
that the model has already
been warm started by
using ML Metadata,
we're able to go ahead and
warm start the model, saving us
both time and compute.
Here's an example of TensorFlow
Model Analysis, also known
as TFMA.
This allows us to
visualize how a model's
been performing over time.
This is a single model
on a time series graph,
so we can see
whether the model has
been improving or degrading.
Tulsee is going to be talking
a little bit more about TFMA
in a bit.
Finally, we have the ability
to reuse the components.
Now, I mentioned before
caching is great.
Caching is great in
production, but it's also great
when you're building your
model the first time.
When you think about
you have your pipeline,
you're probably working
in the static data set,
and you're probably not working
on your features that much.
You're probably spending most
of your time on the estimator.
So with TFX, we more or less
cache through all that part.
So as you're running
your pipeline,
your critical path is
on the model itself.
So you probably wondering, how
do I develop models in this?
This is where the code comes in.
So at the core, we use
TensorFlow estimators.
You can build an estimator
using a Keras inference graph.
You can build it using
a cant estimator,
or you can go ahead
and create your own
using the low-level ops.
We don't care.
All we need is an estimator.
Once we have the estimator,
the next thing we do
is we need to put it back
into a callback function.
In the case of trainer, we have
a trainer callback function.
And you'll see
here the estimator
plus a couple more
parameters are passed back
to the caller of the
callback function.
This is how we call TensorFlow
for the train and evaluate.
Finally, you add your
code, pretty much
the file that had the callback
function and the estimator,
into this TFX pipeline.
So you'll see there in the
trainer, there's a module file,
and the module file has
all the information.
This is what we use to
call back to your function.
This will generate
the save model.
I was also talking about
data dependency graphs.
If you notice here
on the graph, we
don't actually explicitly
say transform runs
and then the trainer runs.
Instead, we're implied
dependency graph
based on the fact that
the outputs of transform
are required as inputs
for the trainer.
So this allows us to couple
task scheduling along
with our metadata awareness.
At this point, we've
talked about components,
we've talked about
the metadata store,
and we've talked about how
to configure a pipeline.
So now, what I'll
do is talk about how
to schedule and execute
using some of the open source
orchestrators.
So we've modified our
internal version of TFX
to support Airflow and Kubeflow,
two popular open source
orchestrators.
We know that there's additional
orchestrators, not all of which
are in open source, so
we built an interface
that allows us to add additional
orchestrators as possible.
And we'd love contributions.
So if somebody out there wants
to go ahead and implement
on a third or a fourth
orchestrator, please let us
know via GitHub, and
we'll help you out.
Our focus is primarily
on extensibility.
We want to be able
to allow people
to extend ML pipelines,
build new graphs as opposed
to the ones that we've
been showing today,
and then also adding
new components
because not all the components
that you need for machine
learning for your particular
machine learning environments
are the ones that
we're providing.
So putting it all back
together, this is the slide
that Gus showed earlier.
At the very beginning, we
have the ExampleGen component
that's going to extract
and generate examples.
Then, we go through the
phases of data validation.
And assuming that
the data is good,
then we go ahead and
do feature engineering.
Provided that the feature
engineering completes,
we train a model,
validate the model,
and then push it to
one or more systems.
This is our typical ML pipeline.
While some of the
components can change--
the draft structure can change--
that's pretty much how we do it.
And what you see here
on the right is Airflow,
and on the left is Kubeflow.
We use the very
same configuration
for both of these
implementations.
And the key thing that
we're looking for in TFX
is portability.
We want portability where
the same configuration
of a pipeline can move
between orchestrators.
We also want to be portable
across the on-prem,
local machine, and
public cloud boundaries.
So going from my single machine
up to running in Google Cloud
with, for example,
Dataflow is really
a one-line change in my pipeline
just to reconfigure Beam.
So that's it for how the
internals of TFX works.
Next up, my colleague
Tulsee will be talking
about model understanding.
TULSEE DOSHI: Awesome.
Thank you.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Tulsee, and I lead
product for the ML Fairness
Effort here at Google.
ML Fairness, like many
goals related to modeling,
benefits from debugging
and understanding
model performance.
So, today, my goal is to
walk through a brief example
in which we leverage
the facets of TFX
that Gus and Kevin spoke about
earlier to better understand
our model performance.
So let's imagine that
you're an e-tailer,
and you're selling shoes online.
So you have a model,
and this model
predicts click-through
rates that
help inform how much
inventory you should order.
A higher click-through
rate implies a higher need
for inventory.
But, all of a
sudden, you discover
that the AUC and
prediction accuracy have
dropped on men's dress shoes.
Oops.
This means that you may have
over-ordered certain shoes
or under-ordered
certain inventory.
Both cases could have direct
impact on your business.
So what went wrong?
As you heard in the
keynote yesterday,
model understanding
is an important part
of being able to
understand and improve
possible causes of
these kinds of issues.
And today, we want to
walk you through how
you can leverage TFX to think
more about these problems.
So first things first,
you can check your inputs
with the built-in TF Data
Validation component.
This component allows you
to ask questions like,
are there outliers?
Are some features missing?
Is there something broken?
Or, is there a shift
in distribution
in the real world that changes
the ways your users might
be behaving that might be
leading to this output?
For example, here's
a screenshot of what
TensorFlow Data Validation might
look like for your example.
Here, you can see
all the features
that you're using
in your data set--
for example, price or shoe size.
You can see how many examples
these features cover.
You can see if any percent
of them are missing.
You can see the mean, the
standard deviation, min,
median, max.
And you can also
see the distribution
of how those features
map across your data set.
For example, if you
look at shoe size,
you can see the distribution
from sizes 0 to 14.
And you can see
that sizes 3 to 7
seem to be a little bit missing.
So maybe we don't actually have
that much data for kids' shoes.
You can now take
this a step further--
so going beyond the
data to actually ask
questions about your model
and your model performance
using the TensorFlow
Model Analysis.
This allows you to
ask questions like,
how does the model perform
on different slices of data?
How does the current
model performance
compare to previous versions?
With TensorFlow
Model Analysis, you
get to dive deep into slices.
One slice could be
men's dress shoes.
Another example could
be what you see here,
where you can actually slice
over different colors of shoes.
The graph in this example
showcases how many examples
have a particular feature.
and the table below allows you
to deep dive into the metrics
that you care about to
understand not just how
your model is
performing overall,
but actually taking
that next step
to understand where your
performance may be skewed.
For example, for
the color brick,
you can actually see
an accuracy of 74%.
Whereas, for shoes
of color light gray,
we have an accuracy about 79%.
Once you find a
slice that you think
may not be performing the
way you think it should,
you may want to dive
in a bit deeper.
You actually now want
to start understanding
why this performance went off.
Where is the skew?
Here, you can extend this
with the what-if tool.
The what-if tool allows
you to understand
the input your
model is receiving
and ask and answer
what if questions.
What if the shoe was
a different color?
What if we were using
a different feature?
With the what if tool, you
can select a data point
and actually look at the
features and change them.
You can play with
their feature values
to be able to see how
the example might change.
Here, for example, we're
selecting a viewed data point.
You can go in and change
the value of the feature
and actually see how the
classification output would
change as you
change these values.
This allows you to
test your assumptions
to understand where there
might be correlations
that you didn't expect
the model to pick up
and how you might go
about tackling them.
The what-if tool is available
as part of the TFX platform,
and it's part of the
TensorBoard dashboard.
You can also use it
as a Jupyter widget.
Training data, test
data, and trained models
can be provided to
the what-if tool
directly from the
TFX Metadata store
that you heard about earlier.
But, the interesting
thing here is
CTR is really just the
model's proxy objective.
You want to really
understand CTR
so that you can think about
the supply you should buy,
your inventory.
And so, your actual
business objectives
depend on something much larger.
They depend on revenue.
They depend on cost.
They depend on your supply.
So you don't just
want to understand
when your CTR is wrong.
You actually want to understand
how getting this wrong
could actually affect
your broader business--
this misprediction cost.
So in order to
figure this out, you
decide you want to join
your model predictions
with the rest of
your business data
to understand that
larger impact.
This is where some of the
component functionality of TFX
comes in.
You could actually
create a new component
with a custom executor.
You can customize
this executor such
that you can actually join
your model predictions
with your business data.
Let's break that down a bit.
So you have your trainer.
You train a model.
And then, you run the evaluator
to be able to get the results.
You can then leverage
your custom component
to join in business data
and export every prediction
to a SQL database where you can
actually quantify this cost.
You can then take
this a step further.
With the what-if tool,
we talked a little bit
about the importance of
assumptions, of testing what
you think might be going wrong.
You can take this
farther with the idea
of understandable baselines.
Usually, there are
a few assumptions
we make about the ways we
believe that our models should
be performing.
For example, I might believe
that weekends and holidays
are likely to have a higher CTR
with my shoes than weekdays.
Or, I may have the hypothesis
that certain geographic regions
are more likely to click
on certain types of shoes
than others.
These assumptions are rules
that I have attributed to how
my models should perform.
So I could actually create a
very simple rule-based model
that could encode
these prior beliefs.
This baseline
expresses my priors,
so I can use them to
tell when my model might
be uncertain or
wrong, or to dive in
deeper if my expectations
were in fact wrong.
They can help inform when the
deep model is overgeneralizing
or when maybe my expectations
are overgeneralizing.
So here again, custom
components can help you.
You can actually build
a baseline trainer
with these simple rules
whose evaluator also
exports to your SQL database.
Basically, you
stamp each example
with its baseline prediction.
So now, you can run queries not
just over the model predictions
and your business data, but also
over your baseline assumptions
to understand where your
expectations are violated.
Understandable
baselines are one way
of understanding
your models, and you
can extend even beyond this
by building custom components
that leverage new and
amazing research techniques
in model understanding.
These techniques
include [INAUDIBLE],,
which Sundir
touched on yesterday
in the keynote, but also
path-integrated gradients,
for example.
Hopefully, this gave you
one example of many ways
that we hope that the
extensibility of TFX
will allow you to go deeper
and extend the functionality
for your own business goals.
Overall, with TensorFlow
Extended you can leverage many
out-of-the-box components for
your production model needs.
This includes things like
TensorFlow Data Validation
and TensorFlow Model Analysis.
TFX also provides flexible
orchestration and metadata,
and building on top of the
out-of-the-box components can
help you further your
understanding of the model such
that you can truly achieve
your business goals.
We're excited to continue
to expand TensorFlow
Extended for more of your use
cases and see how you extend
and expand it as well.
We're excited to
continue to grow the TFX
community with you.
And come to our
office hours tomorrow
if you're still around I/O
to be able to talk to us
and learn more and for
us to be able to learn
from you about your needs
and use cases as well.
Thank you so much
for joining us today,
and we hope this was helpful.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]